joining me now is Lee zeldon he's the
former New York congressman and
gubinatorial candidate Lee do you agree
that if people want to make an impact on
their communities yes the national
stuff's important but the local route is
the way to
go yeah 100% and these at these local
levels you're you're watching the petri
dish of farle lunacy what might be
happening inside of a city council would
be coming to a state capital near you
soon New York City for example they pass
they ban on the safe uh on the hookup
with uh for gas into new construction so
the state capital then ba passes a ban
Statewide on hooking up new construction
to gas uh what's you what you see
leading our nation down in Washington
are politicians who come from these
cities you know Nancy p he comes from
San Francisco in New York Chuck
Schumer's from New York City aoc's from
New York City hakeim Jeff is from New
York City and these local races the
turnout is abysmal and actually when you
when you show up you find out that a lot
of the these longtime Democratic voters
are disenfranchised Democratic voters
who feel like Democratic policies have
been harming them so they're actually
looking for these conservative solutions
they are willing to vote differently but
you have to show up and earn their
support and the last thing I'll tell you
is that a lot of these Democratic voters
register Democrat because they want
their vote to matter they feel like the
only way for their vote to make a
difference is in a Democratic primary to
vote for the most normal person on the
ballot a lot of these registered
Democrats are actually conservative
Democrats or really Republicans uh who
registered Democrats so the votes are
there but we're just not talking to them
on the
right well let's stick with New York
City because the mayor Eric Adams he
disagrees with you he says he's doing a
great job watch two years ago uh the
city was in a free fall we got stuff
done in 2022 2023 what we are really
happy about is how uh we're continuing
to invest in people Public Safety and
public spaces reshaping our streets
making it easier for New Yorkers to
use he's happy about the condition of
New York City Lee are there enough of
these you know more conservative
Democrats registered to eventually throw
out bums like this that aren't fixing
cities you know what's what's wild about
your question is that Adams's biggest
threat is to his left it's not even to
his right uh there are a lot of people
in New York City who feel like he isn't
far left enough which is wild and and
and no this is not the right direction
in the city because it's the same Eric
Adams who will also admit when he's
blaming somebody else like those big bad
magga Republicans who have caused the
migrant crisis they say while he's
calling on President Biden to do
something about our border he won't
actually put the the blame on the feet
of the president who isn't in position
to do something so what he'll say is it
will destroy New York City every once in
a while you get this nugget of of
honesty that might come out of these
blue City Mayors and these Blue State
governors in the case of Eric Adams
what's Wild is that the biggest
vulnerability that he faces electorally
right now is actually on his left they
they think that he isn't socialist and
far-left wacky
enough yeah you do see that in big
cities Minneapolis same thing anybody
that shows a semblance of Sanity gets
primaried and then the city council gets
even crazier and the cities get what
they deserve Lee uh thank thank you very
much hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else